good luck oh good luck
metaphorically right metaphorically okay
so
um serious chess kind of i'll play c5
let's see if he goes into my my prep
i hope he wasn't watching i don't think
he was watching
uh but time out of time
he's debating what to play i know he's
capable of playing a lot of different
lines here
[Music]
okay so far no surprises so either this
or this is
kind of what i'm expecting oh unexpected
i still know a little bit about this
line though knight a4 is a main move
and then it's been a while since i've
looked at this
a 94 castling
yeah this is called the classical
variation which
not too many people play these days at
least at a higher level
because the lines with bishop bishop e3
queen d2
i think offer more of a chance of
refuting the opening
so i guess there's still this move
really
this is some gambit so takes takes
takes i mean there's queen d4 with
knight f6 back
i don't know if this is theory or he's
just like bluffing
i mean there's only one way to find out
there's some bishop i guess bishop c5
but okay let's investigate
i could very well regret this
okay cause i'm up upon
c4 interesting he wants to play c5 and
have a nice hole on d6
so i could castle
a c5 is actually really irritating
if i play d i could play d5 but then
queen c5
knight here maybe that's the way to go
oh i don't know when he said this
do you i don't know if he's referring to
bishop e2 or f4
i'll have to ask him afterwards
so maybe this is some sort of prep
i'm feeling comfortable though i'm only
or i'm i'm up a pawn
and i've completed or i'm kind of
completing development
so there's this mover this move
this bishop is sad though
i play rook b8 too
i'm just trying to contest the b file if
rook b6 i play knight d7
and i square for the knights
and if takes then i just take back and i
control the file
and maybe the knight can just hop hop
back to e4
bishop d3 okay never mind knight does
not want to go to e4
i'm realizing if if i develop the bishop
i lose a pawn
so let's play a5
it's very possible i'll lose the pawn at
some point
but okay the plan is to do this and then
take and then trade
and then win in the end game
so he wants to double up
i'll play bishop d7 still going for
trades
but maybe not right away
rook b4 is kind of interesting
i could play rookie 8 2. going for e5
i don't want to get too long time
learned my lesson from yesterday
oh i take my knights kind of stuck
like queen a7
[Music]
it's actually kind of annoying
i think i'll take and play 94
and maybe suffer
oh this could be difficult
this bishop is so bad
interesting so i could take
[Music]
oh he wants to win
okay i want to play rook b7
and then f6 eventually
oh okay let's play f6 first
i'm still up a pawn though
[Music]
to go for this
i don't know what my plan is just have
to keep moving quickly
maybe h6 eventually g5
this is a terrifying position
close everything down and then hunker
down
i'm still up a pawn i have two connected
passers too
but he's probably playing for a win this
is so weird
yeah let's do this this
oh
oh that was a good move
there goes my pawn and probably
my my hope this pawn is going to be
a weapon
what do i do here i have no plan
maybe this and this
i didn't want to get skewered though
ah wait am i surviving no i'm not
no stalemate tricks well played wow i
got ground down
good game gg but this line that we play
i played it in 2009 in a in a
uh i've i played it i mean i don't know
much openings guys i'm not very
opening guy but i know my i know some
lines i know some games
so i wanted to ask you like f4 i assume
is theory right
yeah i beat so i i put on the shot i
beat mauricio flores
in fact my game should come up because
yeah right yes
in 2009 and that game was a masterpiece
um i mean and this is the only time i
played it on
on a you know real game um but it's very
interesting i think that i think the
best move is not to take the point it
might be like e5 or something
or somewhere i don't remember now but i
i think that taking the pawn is not
correct
i see the the score percentage i i have
the master's database open
um and white scores like really well
after knight takes e4
that's right yeah it just feels very
tough for black like you're
you're upon but but your bishops are
just my [ __ ] are monsters
white bishops are very strong and my
bishop has a hard time coming to life
um so in fact i think probably the worst
movie you make well not
not the losing move but after all this
which is
force you i think you might have to play
c5
oh instead of d5 or i don't know maybe
even c5 here would be interesting
just to give up the pawn and get the
bishop outside
i considered this i just was i was
terrified of these dark squares
yeah but you know maybe you have knight
e4 here after bishop d6
oh because so your bishop b7 now your
bishop is a little better then you can
play something like group ca
obviously yeah i could try and hold my
ground like put the bishop on c6 not an
e4 eventually like
f6 king f7 yeah i think you can do it
because you got better pawn structure i
i
know one thing for a fact the opponent
sees having the pawn on c6 is worse for
you
than than not having the phone that's
for sure yeah
that's actually it makes a lot of sense
yeah and it's sometimes
it's sometimes hard hard to understand
like i'm very materialistic i like to
hold on to material but
it's much better having the the open c
file and the diagonal for the bishop
and i have the same way uh the only
reason i you know
i know this is because i started
position a long time ago and i
i felt the pressure you know but
i would probably not give up the pawn
neither if the first time i see it you
know it's
this counter sure and this is all that i
was going to mention rugby i don't think
i think would be a
i was talking about it that you need to
play a5 bishop a6 even if you
lose some material lose material even if
you lose the a pawn
this is a necessity i think you have to
do it and i maybe i made a mistake on
allowing you to do that
yeah no in hindsight this this makes
total sense i think in the heat of the
moment i was just trying to like trade
rooks and uh
and for fight for the b file thanks for
the follow you guys
um a5 bishop a6 is killer right
yeah it's like i i think it was a very
nice game on your part very instructive
uh example of like positional
compensation
where you sacked material not for like a
raging attack but just for a positional
mind
and the way you were able to convert i
think was um hopefully instructed for
the viewers like the fact
my pieces never came to life and you're
just dominant in that game